Penis circumcision is practiced for thousands of years
often within cultural and religious traditions
But give it to you that you are circumcised or uncircumcised,
affects health improvement, what it is like to feel or to have sex?
Circumcision is a medical procedure that removes penis skinheads,
exposing the glans of the penis.
Although the exact origins and intentions are still being discussed,
at a time when it became commonplace in the English-speaking world (19th century)
Trimming has actually been done to reduce sexual pleasure
and for masturbating,
which was believed to cause many mental and physical illnesses.
But the medical benefits of circumcision came into question in the late sixties
when the research community was opposed to it,
arguing that there is no clear medical benefit
and that the risk of higher blood loss, infection, or death was high.
This resulted in the fall of circumcised men.
In the United States, the hunting hospitalization rate fell from 64.5% in 1979 to 58.3% in 2010,
but the world estimates that only about 33% of men are circumcised.
However, some modern research has shown that it can reduce the risk of developing penile cancer
and infections such as syphilis, gonorrhea and herpes.
It can also reduce the risk of HIV by up to 60%.
The research conducted in Uganda involving heterosexual couples, one of whom was HIV positive
has shown that none of the circumcised men have been infected with HIV for 30 months,
while 40 out of 137 men who did not circumcise HIV.
This proof applies to the entire sub-Saharan Africa, but it is not clearly demonstrated in developed countries
or among homosexual men for which more research is needed.
For women, the circumcised sexual partner most likely has a reduced risk of HPV,
which reduces their risk of developing cervical cancer.
So how does circumcision protect you from STI? (sexually transmitted diseases)
The research conducted by Dr. Price and his team at the University of Northern Arizona
showed that one year after the circumcision of adult men ended with 81% less bacteria on and around their penis.
Dr. Price explained that in unbound men, the skin may be susceptible to infections
because excessive amounts of bacteria can prevent specialized skin cells, known as Langerhans cells,
from stimulating the immune system.
However, with good hygiene, these risks can be minimized.
The benefits of circumcision begin to decrease when you study sexual pleasure.
Studies have shown that removal of the skin reduces the penis sensitivity
The skin is inerved with specialized nerve that can detect light touch,
like nerve on your fingers and lips.
The most sensitive part of the penis is between the transition region
between the outer and inner part of the foreskin
which is a region that is exposed when the skin retreats back during sexual activity.
Research has shown that even the most sensitive part of the circumcised penis
is not sensitive to skin.
But this reduced sensitivity to circumcision could allow men to "last longer" during sex.
One study documented 47 men who had premature ejaculation.
In the research before and after the circumcision, it was found that the time of ejaculation
nearly tenfold after the circumcision, and the satisfaction of the partner was also high.
When it comes to visual inclination for the circumcised or uncircumcised penises,
It is largely based on experience and bias.
The Canadian Pediatric Association claims that due to the low risk of infection in North America,
mandatory circumcision is not justified.
However, in parts of the world where sexually transmitted diseases are present, the benefits of circumcision can overcome the risk.
At the end of the day, if you live in a developed country and keep up to hygiene
then there is no big difference between the two.